NARRATOR: The most feared allied
spy in World War 2
was a woman.
She was an American
named Virginia Hall who
worked as an undercover agent.
But her career almost
never happened.
At just 27, Hall lost her
leg in a hunting accident.
Undeterred, Hall
spent a year learning
to walk on a
cumbersome prosthetic
leg she nicknamed Cuthbert.
Four years later,
World War II broke out.
Determined to help,
she moved to Europe
where she assisted the French
army as an ambulance driver.
Fluent in French and an expert
on the French countryside,
Hall was recruited by a
secret British espionage unit.
She worked as an underground
informant and organizer,
building a network of 90
agents in the south of France.
The gestapo was desperate
to find The Limping Lady
undermining Nazi occupation.
If captured, she would
be tortured and killed.
In 1942, they found her.
But hall fled to Spain on
foot through the snow capped
Pyrenees mountains,
scaling altitudes of 7,500
feet on her prosthetic leg.
By now, America had
learned of Hall's talents
and assigned her to America's
wartime predecessor to the CIA.
They sent her back to
Nazi-occupied France
to spearhead the
underground resistance.
She disguised herself
as an elderly milkmaid,
dyeing her hair gray and
hiding her distinctive limp
with bulky skirts and
an old lady's hobble.
She transmitted intelligence
via radio signals,
coordinating her band of
French resistance fighters.
On D-day, her team
destroyed four
bridges, derailed
freight trains,
and severed phone lines.
By cutting off
Nazi reinforcements
and preventing them
from retreating,
she was instrumental in
securing an allied victory.
After the war in 1945,
President Harry Truman
awarded Hall with the
Distinguished Service Cross,
the second highest US
military award for bravery.
"March On!"
celebrating women who
changed the world.